[Music]
well
azealia banks is in the news again
who is she getting her name national
like drama
person no she's a she's a musical artist
yeah a rapper
but she's more known for like being
controversial
than her music i i well i i agree with
that yeah
but yeah she is a musical artist though
and um
but yeah she's always constantly in some
sort of drama we
tend to talk about her a lot on the show
but this time
she was trending on twitter and it was
for something quite disturbing
and so just warning for you guys it's
just graphic content ahead okay so
trigger warning thank you very much
yeah so um she eating dim sum or
something
well yeah exactly she was eating them
just kidding
no so she ended up posting on her
her her stories she posted
a few a couple videos but one of them is
her digging up something from the ground
and i'll show you the video
and the second one is she's cooking this
thing okay
what yes why does archaeologists know
well i will explain after you see this
video
here we go graphic
content okay
[Music]
so that was her cat and she dug up she
exhumed
uh what like and now she's boiling her
dead cat why in the pot
why how long had i been dead
how do you know that's a cat we should
try fermented on the ground or what
she was saying it was her dead cat i
like how there's music playing and she's
like getting ready to cook some
she's cooking something nice see do you
see this
that is a cat head it's a cat skull
and the world that's pretty gross
immediately
she started like people started going on
twitter like what the [ __ ] like
zilia is cooking her dead cat she's
gonna eat her dead [ __ ] cat what the
[ __ ] is happening this [ __ ] is crazy
um and then she ended up posting on her
her stories yeah any like small size
thing
she said the cat's head is soaking in
peroxide to fully clean him
then i'm taking him to a jewelry shop to
have it gilded
lucifer was an icon he deserves to be
preserved
you girls are not tough like me she
didn't eat it oh my god she didn't eat
it
and that's really that she was just
cooking this cat the meat
meat off of them yeah the meat off okay
and that she's gonna have like take it
to a jewelry
i'm glad she cleared it up before
everyone started doing it on tiktok
i know right yeah so
apparently she names her cat lucifer and
then she has to prove how tough she is
yeah well she's also she also claims to
be
into brujeria and
and like so she's she called herself a
witch and
that she does this [ __ ] she even show
showed like a closet of hers that
i don't have footage of that but she had
she even showed a closet of hers
and saying that this is three years
worth of sacrificing chickens
and it was like all blood dried blood
splattered and she's like real witches
do real [ __ ]
wow yeah i don't know
and so anyway so then people were like
what the dark magic
[ __ ] like something's she's she's
losing it
she also posted this photo here that's
her religion though guys yeah that's her
cauldron yeah
yeah so it's a pink cauldron with two
like cute
and then yeah like look at how much
we've progressed
that people can be openly witches now i
know right
that's really nice persecuted how many
followers does she have
i don't know you want me to look it up
yeah i wanted to go to salem when i was
in massachusetts but i didn't go
why not no because i had to fly out the
next day
but i want to go next time though see
where the witches used to get burned
they have like sites like that probably
so this is where the witches used to get
burned
yeah they got burned there pretty good
they got burned there pretty good and
then so
what's her name again uh uh as
a mississippi azealia she's probably
like
trying to get revenge on all of her
you know anti-witch i guess
enemies yeah do we know what spell she's
trying to cast or anything
i don't know but right now i googled her
name and the new headline says azalea
banks reveal she bought the skull of a
six-year-old girl online
okay okay um schools are kind of cool
though she's
crazy yeah so she's going through a lot
just
pouring she went through a lot of that's
just like her
going on her amazon shopping spree but
it's like a skull shopping spree
yeah oh chickens all this crazy action
might be working for her cause that's
the reason i was asking like what
her following is like she has seven
hundred thousand on instagram
um seven hundred thousand and she's
cooking cats
that's what i saw she should be in a
million yeah i thought it should be like
20 million or something dude you
unfollow though she's cooking too many
cats i i can't i can't do
i can't deal with it the first one's
interesting but the third one
i don't know too many cats yeah maybe
the skull
community is very niche yeah 700 the
witchcraft community
yeah so anyway she posted this other
thing on her story
and it says like now it's the the cat's
jaw and it says titanium
cat jaw ear cuffs with a slick irony
full of lace wig pony that's [ __ ]
that's something that's fashion i don't
know what that says she doesn't look
very witchy to me
but apparently she's saying that she's
gonna use her cat's jaw
as an ear cuff oh she's a modern witch
okay
yeah so she's like reinventing what it
means to look like a witch
she's trying to break the stereotype
okay because the nose is
like not witchy the hair i mean the no
no she doesn't have the witchy hat nose
is not
yeah she did have the cat though she
didn't have a cat
a black cat yeah does she yeah but it's
dead there you go
you just have a wart she doesn't have
the water she's not very green she
doesn't ride around the broomstick yeah
um i don't know man that outfits to uh
maybe it's
halloween pumpkin but i don't know was
hermione a witch
what yeah she's a witch right who's that
no she's a
a half like half half breed right and
then um
a monk no my blood my blood
my muggle blood oh spoiler alert mud
blood yeah
mud blood blood mud blood human half
blizzard
blood that is
yeah wait what is it so muggles are
non-magical
no but what about witches are there
witches yeah
oh they're called wizards right that's
what i'm saying is
that she wasn't a wish it was the
wizards specific warlocks
i think wizards are like i'm sorry the
dudes right and then
witches are the women that's what i
thought that's what i thought
which is i don't even know you're a
wizard harry you're a witch hermione
no that's what i'm asking i don't know i
think so i thought it was gender
specific yeah i don't know is hermione a
witch let's see
they said no she's a [ __ ] english
english muggle-born witch
she is a witch specifically she should
be killed in our witches
yeah yeah i guess so which oh that's
what's called hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
well i knew there's witches but i didn't
know it was like
some harry potter experts you [ __ ]
[ __ ] turned out to be i totally
don't everyone's talking about mug blood
and [ __ ] you guys don't even know she's
a [ __ ] witch you should know before
harry potter
that it was gender specific merlin's not
a witch he's a wizard
yeah yeah i know yeah that's what i
always knew but i didn't know if it was
harry potter versus
no [ __ ] if it was like because they
caught the wizarding world of harry
potter at the universal or whatever
oh world no yeah they don't have
anything
i never met a female wizard harry potter
is a wizard so they named it
after him yeah wizarding world i think
we figured it out now
which is in wizards did you guys ride
the harry potter ride
i did i haven't been there yet it's like
magical [ __ ] talking about it
things are dead cats let's talk about a
wand after harry potter it's witchcraft
you think it was like after she like had
the cat buried for a while she was
hanging out with her other witch friends
and they were like
why didn't you do this with the cat and
she's like oh good idea so she had to
like dig her
do you think the witch community like
burns her for doing
it wrong and they're like no you're not
supposed to boil it oh my god you're
supposed to put in the oven you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah who knows they probably have
their
things but she's saying that back in
2015 that her interest in magic came
from her mother so
her mom was a queen witch no i mean
probably probably her mom
did that or her mom probably her mom
boiled the cat too
she's cursing me guys i'm just kidding
is she a good witch or is she an evil
witch
oh yeah can she get in trouble for
sacrificing chickens
well don't we all yeah but they have to
do it like humane right you can't just
torture a chicken
i don't know if they sacrifice it that
way i don't know ask the tyson
company if they if they do it humanely
they are getting in trouble they are
they're like yeah it's humane we chucked
it into a wood chipper
oh the cat died three months ago oh from
the time that she exhumed
yeah imagine how maggody it is when you
dig it up by stinky oh you gotta boil it
nasty
that's why she had it in the bag oh you
think the whole time she was like yeah
i'm so hard
so hard right now she's like digging up
this cat full of maggots probably
because she ended up posting on her own
story too she said why do you think i
would eat a dead cat when i can barely
eat a dead cow it's called taxidermy
oh so she's vegan i guess that's a vegan
barely
i see sometimes saxon jeremy isn't
taxidermy
you stuff um no that's one point
it's about being a vegan
getting bones is i guess in that in that
realm really yeah because we recently
had a story here where a guy
that lost his leg from below the knee he
was
he was hitting up a whole bunch of
taxidermy places to try to get her
i mean his bones deserve the bone yeah
and you do it by boiling huh that makes
sense
that's interesting um yeah i don't know
but yeah that's why azealia banks was
trending recently
a lot of people are like she's crazy
that's why i don't follow her she's too
crazy yeah
and then so she also posted more things
too she said
christianity literally has human
sacrifice as the central piece of its
doctrine
please shut y'all cannibal vampire asses
i think she says oh she's talking about
jesus on the cross
yeah i i'm assuming lol and go buy the
pastor in new mercedes lol
catholics ritualistically consume the
body and blood of christ at mass
either the communion is bunk because it
replaces true flesh and blood with bread
and wine or
catholics are all essentially vampires
and cannibals dude do you think the
vampire community is like come on dude
we didn't do anything on this one
i know right come on bro why you gotta
talk [ __ ] to us
stay low-key and just keep doing it i
would i would be christian just for
communion
communion always looked delicious but i
was never the welch's grape juice
christian you ain't catholic
either one they both do communion oh i
didn't know christians yeah
they still have the ceremony but they
use welch's grape juice and that's the
[ __ ]
in a little shot glass have you ever
been to a cool christian uh
group where they know that they're cool
yeah the ones that have a rock band yeah
like all that stuff she prays that
way yeah and you can dress however you
want to church here like
hey i've been to one of those yeah
they're fun it's fun yeah
[Music]
you